Bernie Sanders is now the front-runner
right yeah
yeah now that he's the front-runner he's
getting a lot of attention people are
asking a lot of harder questions now
that he's for example Bernie Sanders is
now refusing did you hear this refusing
to release his full medical records that
is true yeah the senator defended
himself he said it's not my fault no one
kept records during the bubonic plague
they didn't have this record-keeping
cheat on him I wouldn't want to see his
medical records
I just imagine like nine guys with
wheelbarrows and just tons of pages tons
of pages well those the heart attack at
nine 1885 he's fine he'll be fine don't
worry about it I don't want the Bernie
bros after me please please leave me
alone you got yeah are you back there a
guy do uh okay good leave me alone
present Trump's in India oh really yeah
present Trump's in India and 100,000
people came to a stadium to hear him
speak yeah which keep it in mind in
India that's like playing to an empty
house that's open mics get 200,000
people are like we're sorry mr.
president II couldn't get anyone no it's
true President Trump arrived in India
there was kind of an awkward moment when
Trump pulled out his laptop and asked
who can help me that was a there's more
he said which one of you is Gary I need
Gary
where is Gary you don't get to choose
the jokes I'm just a free show get over
boy the first if you paid to get in I'd
listen to you
here's interesting story I told you how
the how the times are changing 89 year
old billionaire investor Warren Buffett
said he finally traded in his flip phone
for an iPhone yeah that cuts a sign
attempts yeah when asked why Buffett
said porn
the Bernie bros are back with me now we
like porn
[Applause]